Microsoft is very interested in health
care problems because the healthcare
industry has got a lot of Technology a
lot of data and yet we feel that we're
not making the best use of that
technology and our data
Novartis approached us they're very
interested in the ability to assess and
diagnose the progression of multiple
sclerosis which is a very tricky disease
to try and assess multiple sclerosis is
a disease of the central nervous system
and it can affect people's everyday
lives so it can affect their their
balance their motor abilities their
ability to walk to eat can also affect
cognitive abilities and vision we saw a
real possibility to use all of the
expertise that we have in the building
around machine learning computer vision
and the design of user experience is
going to bring all of those different
disciplines together to provide some
data that's going to help the expert
make a better assessment the role of
machine learning in SSMS is to find an
automated way to classify the patient's
condition given a certain set of
movements so the goal is simply to
standardize multiple sclerosis is
currently assessed by a neurologist
using a clinical standardized rating
scale so they might ask a patient to
stretch out their hands touch their nose
walk for five meters and this is where
technology has a real strength SSMS
system provides a consistent quantified
measure of Moshe bility over time as
2pcs progresses you can see stronger and
stronger impairments on the motor skills
and the machine learning basically just
tries to figure out where do certain
signatures start for which category and
how do they sort of develop as you cross
the boundary to the next category
at the moment the SSMS project is
focused around providing this consistent
measure in clinical trials we worked
with a team at Novartis Pharma
who helped us understand what kinds of
things are needed in clinical trials and
how does that we go about partnering
with with clinics it requires multiple
stakeholders and what we've been able to
do in this collaboration is work with
University Hospitals Microsoft Research
as well as our own
Novartis research teams to bring
together the best talent needed to
completely change the paradigm in how we
assess MS patients disability
progression we're not trying to replace
a neurologist or the nurse what we're
trying to do instead is to very much
bolster or augment the kinds of
expertise that they already have is
there to really help the doctor give a
consistent measurement over time to help
the patient make the best decisions they
can about their treatment